[Música]
las noticias de la salud de esta mañana
con Natalia plazas a Natalia Buen día
para usted Buenos días Ángela bien
Natalia vamos a arrancar hablando de
alzheimer porque hay avances respecto a
esta enfermedad el pasado jueves la
agencia de medicamentos de Estados
Unidos otorgó su aprobación para un
fármaco que ralentiza su desarrollo sí
Ángela estamos hablando concretamente de
que será que es un fármaco que ha sido
desarrollado para administrar justamente
en las primeras fases de desarrollo de
esta enfermedad la fda ya había otorgado
su una autorización de emergencia para
este fármaco en enero sin embargo en los
últimos meses se hizo un nuevo estudio
para cerciorarse de los resultados y de
que realmente sea eficaz y seguro para
las personas que lo utilicen este
estudio se practicó en 1800 pacientes de
alzheimer y sus conclusiones
llegaron a que el tratamiento retrasa la
progresión de esta enfermedad en un 27%.
concretamente
los pacientes que recibieron dosis de
este fármaco retrasaron en cinco meses
la progresión de la enfermedad respecto
a quienes recibieron un placebo sin
embargo cabe puntualizar y esto lo han
recalcado bastante Ángela Los
investigadores que no se trata de una
cura que no va a mejorar las capacidades
cognitivas de los pacientes que ya
tienen Alzheimer y que tampoco va a
finalizar con la enfermedad recordemos
que el alzheimer es un trastorno
cerebral Irreversible y progresivo el
fármaco lo que hace es conseguir
eliminar los depósitos que se forman
entre las neuronas de una proteína
llamada Beta almiloide estos depósitos
crean digamos unos
unas placas entre las neuronas y Esto
justamente es lo que crea el deterioro
cognitivo en las personas hasta el
momento ningún medicamento había logrado
frenar O ralentizar mejor dicho la
progresión de esta enfermedad y por ello
Los investigadores del fármaco lo
celebran veamos
es algo pequeño pero sigue siendo
prometedor Cuando no tenemos ningún otro
tratamiento disponible
Qué significa para nosotros
tal vez le brinde mejores días de
Independencia antes de llegar a una
etapa de demencia
Pues estamos hablando potencialmente de
mejorar la calidad de vida de las
personas que tienen este padecimiento
Natalia sin embargo esta aprobación
también genera dudas que son por
supuesto muy normales como por ejemplo
si existen contraindicaciones para la
toma de de este fármaco sí Ángela
justamente la fda dio la aprobación al
fármaco pero incluyendo advertencias
importantes en las cajetillas de hecho
destacó que en algunos casos durante el
estudio algunos pacientes en Casos
extraños vale la pena recalcar el
medicamento puede causar efectos graves
como han sido hemorragias cerebrales
otro interrogante que también ha sido
bastante importante para resolver en los
últimos días es cómo será el acceso de
las personas a este fármaco porque
actualmente tiene un costo de
26.500 dólares anuales es un costo muy
alto para los pacientes Medicare que es
el servicio público de Estados Unidos ya
ha dicho que financiará en un 80% el
acceso a este fármaco para los pacientes
sin embargo
esto significa que las personas que
tienen Alzheimer y que quieran acudir a
este fármaco sin embargo tendrán que
seguir pagando unos 6000 dólares anuales
lo que significa también unos altos
costos para estas personas sin embargo a
pesar de todas estas dificultades hay
pacientes que han formado parte del
estudio de El fármaco y que celebran que
exista ya una posibilidad de ralentizar
sus efectos veamos
Esto no es un paseo por el parque estás
hablando de una gran enfermedad y ella
es la que está haciendo el viaje Así que
es difícil pero por otro lado aquí
estamos Joan conduce todos los días a la
tienda de comestibles Y si arregla el
pelo se arregla las uñas y ya sabes es
como si la vida continuará lo cual es
realmente una gran cosa
Pues bueno es una victoria en medio de
una enfermedad muy difícil de tratar
vamos a hacer un cambio de tema Natalia
si le parece Porque hay otro asunto bien
preocupante que tiene que ver con la
agencia reguladora de medicamentos en
Europa que está investigando dos
fármacos de la farmacéutica nordis que
esto luego de que en Islandia se
reportaran casos de pensamientos suicida
o de pensamientos de autolesión sí
Ángela se trata de los medicamentos o
sempic y saxenda el regulador de salud
de Islandia reportó dos casos de
personas que habían tomado ompic y que
habían tenido pensamientos suicidas y el
caso de una persona que había consumido
zackenda y que había tenido pensamientos
de autolesionarse
es un medicamento que tiene como
principio activo la semaglutida este
medicamento la semaglutida concretamente
ha sido usado durante años para tratar
la diabetes tipo 2 sin embargo también
en los últimos meses está siendo
utilizado cada vez más en tratamientos
de adelgazamiento debido a que tiene la
capacidad de generar una sensación de
saciedad en las personas entre tanto
tiene un principio activo que es muy
parecido y se llama la
liraglutina la agencia de medicamentos
de Estados Unidos ya Lleva años
advirtiendo de que estos dos componentes
activos han causado casos de
pensamientos suicidas entre
las personas que lo han consumido hasta
el momento sin embargo la fda la fda ha
dicho que no existe una causalidad
probada entre el consumo de estos dos
medicamentos y los pensamientos suicidas
entre los pacientes que las consumen
pero todo esto realmente también es
bastante relativo porque existen otros
medicamentos a base de
de Estos principios activos que sí
llevan ya en Estados Unidos
obligatoriamente una advertencia de que
deben ser controlados por especialistas
debido a que justamente Ángela provocan
este tipo de pensamientos entre algunos
pacientes pues Natalia habrá que ver qué
avances se dan en esta investigación
pero no les va bien a estos medicamentos
que han sido utilizados principalmente
para el abuso Más allá del cuidado de la
diabetes Así que tampoco es muy buena la
perspectiva si me lo pregunta después de
todos los casos que hemos tratado acá
Muchísimas gracias Natalia Muchas
gracias Ángela